yeah we have indeed let me tell you what
Nicholas sturgeon has been seeing in the
last uh few minutes she has said that
this has been a traumatic time uh of
course let's remember this is the former
first Minister whose home was raided her
husband the former chief executive of
the SNP uh Peter motto was arrested at
just a number of weeks ago describing
this period as traumatic saying that she
has not spoken to police Scotland as
part of this long-running police
investigation examining fundraising and
funds of the party the biggest political
party in Scotland she also said that she
was given no notice of that police raid
at the home that she shares with Peter
Morrow a number a number of weeks ago
she also denied that the timing of her
resignation that shock resignation
earlier on this year that brought many
people bright by surprise her leaving
after more than 3 000 days at the helm
here in Scotland she denied that this
looming police investigation this
looming number of arrests that we have
witnessed in recent weeks played a
factor in that role to in that decision
to resign she was also leveled uh with
questions around criticism of secrecy
this has been a long-running accusation
that Nicholas sturgeon and her husband
Peter model the two at the top of the
SMP have uh dealt with in recent times
around keeping secrets around what was
happening at the high ranks of the party
she denied that that was the case and
denied as well that they were keeping
out of the public domain the fact that
they had Auditors at the fact that they
did not have Auditors at that point in
time I am now being told that we can now
hear what Nicholas sturgeon has had to
say in the last few minutes
I understand
I think he'd be further from the truth I
could not have anticipated in my worst
nightmares and what would have unfolded
over at the past few weeks I believe the
SNP notwithstanding the the real
difficulties that surround the packages
now is in good shape and I think Hamza
will take it too even better
what appeared to be a tearful exchange
from the former first Minister Nicholas
sturgeon at Hollywood at this afternoon
she said she was going to make no
comment about this motorhome that was an
asset of the SMP apparently in the
region of around a hundred thousand
pounds one person who has been making a
comment is the man who has just gone
through that gate pictures of Colin
Beatty arriving home last week when he
had been facing uh hours of questioning
a day of detention by police he making
that major Revelation this afternoon
that he did not know that the SNP owned
this motorhome why is that significant
well it's at the very center of this
long-running police investigation it has
been seized outside the home of Peter
Morrow's mother Nicholas sturgeon's
mother-in-law that is currently in
police custody we understand in Glasgow
so there are questions around who knew
what and when around that vehicle
specifically and it's also interesting
that Colin Beatty says he did not know
about that motorhome at all because he
is the man whose name is on the latest
audited accounts of the SMP at 80 000
pounds more than 80 000 pounds in Motor
Vehicles on those latest audited
accounts no doubt his intervention this
afternoon will create more more
questions than answers indeed Connor
Thank you